happy sabbath
everyone welcome to the official
fourth episode of the feel the pillars
series with the word inspired
i'm your host denise mccurchin and i'm
joined with special guests
elder randy skeet kadisha modest
jonathan david archie
and carissa hunt to discuss
righteousness
by faith let us pray dear lord
holy and reverend is your name
we are unworthy and undone
but please forgive us of our sins
cleanse us from all unrighteousness and
speak today
in jesus name amen
in episode three with dr walter fight we
affirm
that in christ we can have victory
over sin but how does this
victory look how does a righteous
life look how do we even become
righteous
in the first place place what does it
mean
to have the mind of christ
stay tuned for the q a segment with
elder randy skeet
as we answer these questions by the
grace of god so please
don't keep the word to yourself take a
moment
to share like subscribe and comment
by god's grace we'll be monitoring the
chat and maybe your question
please if you are online mute yourselves
all right so we'll be monitoring the
chat
and by god's grace your question will be
posed for those of you that are on zoom
this program is being live streamed to
youtube and
facebook and can be replayed there by
typing in
my name now today
we are blessed to have sister kadisha
modest minister more than just
a hill sister khadijah modest
beyond being modest is an elementary
school teacher
and always a pleasure to be around
so please welcome sister kadisha
happy sabbath everyone i hope you all
are blessed
by this song
[Music]
so
he sculpted the mountain
with such great skill
yet when he made
it was more than just
a heel
it was more than a mountain
[Music]
for the thirsty
oh
it was more than just
a
[Music]
oh
my place you see
i was insane
that myself
[Music]
it was more than
it became a fountain
for
[Music]
oh
it was more than just
[Music]
crawl
it was more than
just
[Music]
amen amen when jesus
made calvary it was more
than just a hill praises be to the name
of god that our savior
has gone or went already the extra mile
for our sakes thank you for that
peace sister khadijah modest
now today we are joined by international
speaker
elder randy skeet he is a husband
and a humble man of god and i can say
that he is a lover of god and people
and treats each person with the utmost
respect
he is a graduate of oakwood university
and of the seventh-day adventist
theological seminary
at andrews university where he studied
for the ministry
and as he would say i pray
and ask you to pray with me that god
will
put his words in his mouth
let us listen be reverent and think
as he speaks please welcome elder
randy skeet thank you very much my good
sister
i am delighted to be with you and your
audience
and i pray that the spirit of god who is
the spirit of truth
will guide our willing minds along the
path of truth
because it is truth alone that
sanctifies and
christ himself is the truth so i'm
grateful for the privilege of being here
and i hope and pray that we will emerge
from this meeting
a wiser and clearer in our thinking
regarding the
central teaching of the bible which is
righteousness or justification by faith
so i'm ready for your questions but
before i answer them let me offer my
prayer
father in heaven we come to you in the
name of jesus christ
we ask you today god forgive us where we
have offended you
because sin interferes with the
comprehension of truth
grant us your grace do for us what we
cannot do for ourselves and that is to
save us
speak clearly through me i pray put your
words in my mouth
put your ideas in my mind and put the
humility of christ
in my heart bless everyone listening i
pray
if anyone listening is ill or any way
suffering
heal the person they god remove the
coronavirus
is if that is the problem strengthen
your people they god
because health spiritual and physical is
your desire for
us i offer this prayer in jesus name
amen amen amen thank you elder skeet for
that prayer
and we'll move right along the first
question is actually four questions in
one
what is righteousness all right
that's a very very important question i
mean
absolutely important let the bible
explain what righteousness is let us go
to genesis
chapter 6 and as you're looking for
genesis chapter 6 keep in mind that the
bible is not a dictionary
so sometimes in the finding words we
need not try to define it as though we
are reading a dictionary
the bible is not necessarily a
dictionary
all right nor is the dictionary a bible
in genesis 6 from verse 1 to 7 we have a
description
of the wicked lives that were lived that
led to god sending the flood we have in
verse 5 of genesis 6
and i'm reading from the king james
version of the bible
and god saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart
was only evil continually and it
repented the law that he had made man on
the earthly grieving at his heart
and the lord said i will destroy man
whom i have created from the face of the
earth
both man and beast and the creeping
thing in the fowls of the air
for it repenteth me that i have made
them now
god does not destroy what is good he
only destroys what is sinful verse it
says
but noah found grace in the eyes of the
lord
verse 9 says noah was a just man
meaning noah was the very opposite of
what you read in verses one to seven
and what we read in verses one to seven
is simply a life
of sin noah by god's own declaration
found grace noah was different noah was
a just
man now the hebrew word for just is the
same word for righteous
and so when we go to chapter 7 of the
book of genesis
verse 1 the bible says and the lord said
unto noah
come thou and all thy house into the ark
for thee have i seen righteous before me
in this generation righteousness
therefore
is the very opposite of sin let me say
that again
righteousness is the very opposite of
sin
now having said that let's add some
layers to that so we have
a fuller and a more robust meaning of
what
righteousness is let us go to psalm 119
we'll read verse 172 psalm 119
verse 172
the psalmist says my tongue shall speak
of thy words
for all thy commandments are
righteousness
righteousness is what the commandments
of god express
now we know the law is a reflection of
the very
character of god we call it a transcript
of his character
and this is not a seventh-day adventist
teaching this is a teaching of the
christian world
based on the bible the law is a
transcript
because nobody has seen god no one has
actually seen god in operation
except in the life of christ and so god
gives us an idea of his
righteousness in the law that he gave
and of course
lived out in the life of christ and so
the bible says
all thy commandments are righteousness
and so righteousness is
what the law expresses which is the very
character of god
in deuteronomy chapter 6 verse 25
deuteronomy 6 verse 25 the bible says
and this shall be our righteousness
if we observe to do all these
commandments before the lord our god
as he hath commanded us and this shall
be
our righteousness it shall be our
righteousness
if we observe to do all these
commandments
before the lord our god as he has
commanded us
in isaiah 51 7
god says hearken unto me the
ye that know righteousness the people in
whose heart is my law
hearten unto me ye that no righteousness
the people in
whose heart is my law and so again we
have
righteousness under law of god
righteousness
is what the law of god expresses because
it expresses the very
character of god of course we get help
from the servant of the lord
she tells us in faith and works page 100
paragraph 1 i believe it is
righteousness is obedience to the law so
that righteousness
is what the law expresses
and the law expresses the very character
of god
this was the life jesus lived it is the
very opposite
of sin
amen amen thank you for giving us those
different verses that speak about
righteousness and you know as you were
going through the verses genesis
chapter six from verses one to nine and
then
genesis chapter seven verse one isaiah
57 verse one deuteronomy chapter six i
believe it was
it reminded me that one way that we can
study the bible
is to literally get a key word so if we
want to find out more about
righteousness talk like have that in our
mind go to a concordance and look in the
bible where we see
instances of righteousness and allow the
verses to inform
each other here a little there a little
thank you for that answer of the skeet
god's
righteousness is in his law it is the
opposite of sin
now the next question in this first one
is what is faith
all right that is also easily answered
by the bible let's go to matthew chapter
eight we read from verse five
matthew eight from verse five and when
jesus was entered into capernaum they
came unto him
a centurion beseeching him and saying
lord
my servant life at home sick of the
palsy and grievously tormented
and jesus said unto him i will come and
heal him
the centurion answered and said lord i
am not worthy that thou should come
under my roof but speak the word only
and my servant shall be healed
for i am a man under the authority
having soldiers unto me
and i say to this man go and he goeth to
another comedy cometh until my servant
do this and he does it
when jesus heard that he marveled and
said
i have not found so great faith nor not
in israel
what made jesus marvel the centurion
believe
that whatever jesus said would
happen and jesus called that
faith in other words faith is simply
a total surrender to the reliability
and the trustworthiness of thus saith
the
lord faith is the faith is believing
with all your heart and your soul and
your mind on your strength and your
might and your understanding that what
god says
will come to pass this is the simple
definition of faith i know we sometimes
say
faith is the substance of things hope
for the evidence of things not seen and
then people have all kinds of
uh wrestling matches trying to un
explain that
but the the event or the incident in
matthew 8 where jesus
marveled at faith he marveled at the
fact
that this centurion not an israelite had
such trust in the word of god
and by the way the first lesson of the
bible
is the word of god is absolutely
reliable
genesis 1 and god said and god said and
god said
and it was so and it was so and it was
so accepting that
is faith and so faith is accepting
and believing that whatever
god says he will do
without the word of god there can be no
faith that's why romans 10 17 says faith
cometh by hearing
and hearing by the word of god but that
hearing in that verse is not just
the use of the air it needs to heed
you hear it and you respond to it you
heed
this is the faith the faith that works a
lot of people they hear
they never respond the hearing of romans
10 17
is that which includes a response faith
is total trust of your entire being
to thus set the lord accepting on the
bible's authority
that god will never go back on his word
as verily as let there be light that
there was light
that applies to any statement god makes
faith is simple
amen thank you so much elder skeet faith
is simple
complete acceptance of the word of god
so we have defined what righteousness is
and we have defined what
faith is and now the question is what is
righteousness
by faith good question very
intelligently expressed
i like the order of your questions
righteousness by faith
refers to what god does for a sinner
because he or she
cannot do it for himself or herself
righteousness
is god's way of delivering us from the
power of sin
because we cannot save ourselves as long
as there's this thing called calvary
it tells us we cannot save ourselves
and righteousness by faith is the means
whereby
god makes a person fit or uh
give the person a title for heaven and
the fitness for heaven because it's the
same righteousness
so righteousness by faith is the means
whereby
god saves a sinner and god preserves
that saved sinner
amen so righteousness by faith is the
means
of our salvation
amen let me give an example someone
saved on the spot
in luke chapter 18 we read from verse 9.
luke 18 reading for verse 9 and i will
pray again
father as i talk about this very central
bible subject give me the right words i
pray please
in the name of your son i pray amen and
he spake a parable unto certain that
trusted in themselves that they were
righteous
and despise others two men went up into
the temple to pray
the one a pharisee the other republican
the pharisee stood and prayed thus with
himself lord
i thank thee and i am not as other men
are
extortioners unjust adulterers
or even as this publica i fast
twice in the week i give tithes of all
that i possess
now he is presenting to god all his good
works in quotation marks
in other words he's telling god here's
why i qualify
for your salvation verse 13 when the
publican
would not lift standing afar off would
not lift up so much as his
eyes unto heaven but smote upon his
breasts saying god
be merciful to me a sinner in verse 14
jesus said
i tell you this man went down to his
house
justified rather than the other what did
christ mean by that
he went down to his house in a right
relationship with god
this is righteousness by faith now he
had to continue to
live that life are you following me so
in the instant he said god
be merciful to me a sinner we have to
see within that statement
he's acknowledging he cannot save
himself
he is so aware of his nothingness he
will not even
lift his head he does not deserve to
look up where god lives
and so with his head towards the ground
confessing his helplessness
and his dirty condition i'm a sinner
he said be merciful and there is no
mercy
outside of calvary calvary is the
highest
expression of mercy it is the gospel
he asked to be saved and he was
saved right there then went down to his
house
according to jesus justified
or made right with god
in that instant he was justified and as
i said earlier
he clearly had to walk in that way
because the mind will say
as ye have received christ jesus the
lord
so walking in galatians chapter 2 i
believe is verse 6
not galatians colossians 2 6 as he
therefore have received
christ jesus the lord which is what that
republican did so
walking in him you receive him by faith
you walk in him by face
righteousness by faith is that process
whereby god
justifies or makes a person right with
him
he puts him in a right standing and he
puts him in a right
state as he continues to remain in that
standing let me say that again
for instance ella white writes in uh the
faith i live by page 116 paragraph two
the righteousness by which we're
justified
is imputed the righteousness by which
we're sanctified
is imparted the first is our title
for heaven to heaven the second is our
fitness for heaven
so righteousness but justification by
faith that instant transformation
gives you a title to heaven but now you
have to be made fit
let me explain it this way here is the
king sitting on the throne
his successor will be his son his son is
three years old
the son has the right he has the title
but he's not yet fit he has the right
but he does not have the fitness if the
king dies
and the boy is still three there has to
be a regen because the boy does not have
the fitness
when you come to christ in the instant
you acknowledge you are
nothing you cannot save yourself all
your righteousness is filthy right
and you call for mercy in believing that
christ is your salvation in that instant
you're covered by the very righteousness
of christ which
is the righteousness of god because
there are two versions of divine
righteousness
that is that then gives you a title
now you have to learn as newborn babes
desire the sins now you are aware that
you're a son of god
if your confession was genuine as you
have received the spirit
in that instant you now want to walk and
live as a son of god
and you seek that power from the same
person who justified you in that instant
it's the same person who preserves you
as you walk because the bible says he
that endures to the end
salvation is not flashing the path you
must continue
in your justified state ella white
writes
faith and works page 100 paragraph one
god
requires the entire surrender of the
heart in order for justification to take
place
and in order for man to retain
justification
he must continually obey god so in a
certain sense
sanctification is the constant retention
of justification
you have to hold on to it
and it's the same you use to hold on to
it the righteousness of christ
two times of power his power is his
righteous life
and by the way it is mediated to us
through
the word it is through the word
and james 1 18 of his own will begetting
us
with the word of truth justification
conversion the new birth is accomplished
by the word when it is received
by faith and faith means he said he can
change my life
i accept that fact
and god honors that as he honored
abraham who believed
that his barren wife could have a child
genesis 15 16 god counted that to him as
righteousness
all right dr mccarthy next question amen
well elder skeet you have effectively
answered two of our questions
the next one was how is righteousness
imputed
uh which he spoke about so i'll move on
to the next which is
what does it mean to have the faith of
jesus this is
based on revelation 14 where it says
here is the patience of the saints
here are they that keep the commandments
of god and
have the faith of jesus so what is
what does it mean to have the faith of
jesus
all right the faith of jesus there are
two things in that verse revelation 14
here is the patience of the saints yeah
are they that
keep the commandments of god you could
also say and keep the faith of jesus you
hold on to it now
the faith of jesus may be expressed as
the
faithfulness of jesus to do what he says
he can do for you
now in um the 1888 ellen white
idiot materials pitch 217 paragraph four
she writes these very very eye-opening
words
commenting on this very thing the faith
of jesus listen carefully
here's the quotation the faith of jesus
it is taught of but not understood
what is the faith of jesus or what
constitutes the faith of jesus
that belongs to the third angel's
message
jesus becoming our sin bearer
that he might become our sin pardoning
savior
he was treated the way we deserve to be
treated
he was treat he was treated the way we
deserve to be treated because he was
treated as a sinner
she goes on to say he came to our world
and took our sins that we might take
his righteousness and here's how the
quotation ends
faith in the ability of christ
to save us amply and
fully and entirely is
the faith of jesus
faith in the ability of christ
to save us amply
and fully and entirely they all mean the
same thing
is the faith of jesus meaning
the faith of jesus is believing that
regardless
of your situation jesus christ can
deliver you
deliverance is his speciality
that's what the cross is all about you
can call it restoration deliverance
deliverance breaking the power of satan
making somewhat right with god
regardless of the person's condition
this is christ's expertise and the faith
of jesus
is believing with all your heart that
christ can deliver you regardless of
your condition
and the depth of your degradation he can
deliver you
but if you look at the verse they keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus
when christ delivers you he delivers you
from violating the law
and brings into a position where you can
abide by his law
the faith of jesus is the belief
that christ is able to save me
amply fully and
entirely because he took my sins that i
might take
his righteousness that is the faith of
jesus
do not believe he can come to sin they
don't believe
the faith of jesus contains the belief
it is the belief
that christ can deliver me completely
christ didn't die to improve people he
died to transform them
wow wow christ did not die to improve
people he died to transform them
transformed wow praise god thank you for
that
elder skeet and for that quote and from
ellen white that tells us that
having the faith of jesus is the belief
that
christ alone is able to amply save us
and you know it's it's a relief that we
don't have it's not our works that saves
us we don't need to go to a pastor a
priest our parents
a friend jesus is all sufficient
to take care of our salvation
you see jesus in uh in matthew 12
from verse 33 jesus said either make the
tree good
and his fruit good or the tree evil and
his fruit evil corrupt
for the tree is known by his food in
other words a good tree
cannot bring forth evil fruit and our
corrupt tree
cannot bring forth good fruit that's
from matthew 7 15 to uh 19.
now when i try to save myself
the very best efforts i make which may
win me a medal from earthly powers
is considered as filthy rise in the eyes
of god
because in order for me to do good i
must first
be made good and i hope you understand
what i'm saying let me say it again
in order for me to do good in the eyes
of god
i must be made good because the goodness
of the act is based upon the source
a good heart will produce good actions a
corrupt heart will produce current
actions
so jesus says out of the abundance of
the heart the mouth speaketh
a good man out of the good treasure of
his heart bringing forth good things
an evil man out of the evil treasure
bringing forth evil things
and so in order for me to do what's good
i must be made good
but i cannot make myself good so
all my attempts to make myself good
produces
filthy work and simply worsens my
condition
i am building evil upon evil because i
cannot make myself good jesus
has to make me good and when he makes me
glory makes me righteous
then i can produce what he requires of
me which is
a life in harmony with god's law a
sinner cannot make himself
or herself righteous because our best
efforts are described in isaiah 64 6
as fifth derives i say it doesn't say
your sins are as filthy right that's too
obvious
what you consider good is viewed by god
as filthy right in other words there's a
lesson that we all
need to learn and never forget there is
absolutely
nothing a sinner can do to save himself
we come to god in the dust in humility
acknowledging only god can
save us
amen amen thank you for that elder skeet
and while we are on this topic of jesus
someone has asked will anyone be saved
without hearing the name of jesus
yes yes the name of
jesus j-e-s-u-s those five letters do
not contain power
the name of jesus is who he is you see
who the character
thou shalt call his name jesus for he
shall save his people from their sins
there are many men in hispanic or latino
countries that are called
jesus it's the same thing they call
jesus
the power is not in five letters the
power is in what that name stands for
his life his righteous life
his unselfish life his self-renouncing
love his self-sacrificing love
and there are those who've never heard
that name but that's the way they live
based on the life they have and they
will be in the kingdom of god
amen amen i i even recall
um i believe ellen white writes can't
remember where but for those that have
never had
access or had the ability to access the
physical word of god
the lord can reveal himself to them
through nature
sin god's book was nature for adam and
eve to learn of him
because of sin now we have the bible but
nature is still god's important book of
instruction
you see the things of the bible may be
learned by observing nature
so yes someone not having a bible can
still receive
revelation from god because god reveals
based on what he sees
in you the heart of a man or a woman is
that person willing to receive
a lot of us surrounded by bibles who
would end up in the in the fires of hell
so it is not how many bibles you have
what is your mindset
are you do you have a mind to do what's
right even though you've never heard the
name of jesus
that's what god is looking for and god
can save that person
amen amen now you may have answered this
question but someone from zimbabwe has
asked will anyone
well excuse me how can i achieve or get
the faith of jesus is there a process of
achieving it
you have to develop your own faith
the faith of jesus is christ's ability
our belief in his ability to save us
completely now our
faith that faith we must exercise in
christ's ability that faith grows and
grows and grows now
romans 10 17 says faith cometh by
hearing
and hearing by the word of god the bible
says
faith is made perfect by words that
works by being obedience
so as we obey god's word our faith in
god grows
it becomes stronger it becomes more
tenacious
in its grasp of the promises of god so
our faith grows through the word
as we study god's word and obey our
faith grows and we cling even more
tightly to christ
as our only hope of salvation so it is
not
christ's faith in his father that saves
us it is
we we're called upon to belief on the
lord jesus christ
believe and when you do that then christ
does the work of salvation is by the way
faith is not the thing that saves you
let me say that it is not faith that
saves you because if faith is what saves
you
you can exercise the faith and say i'm
saying myself it is
god responding to the faith it is christ
who saves us not the faith it is not
your hope that saves you
it is not whatever your time giving that
saves you it is
christ alone but faith is the means
whereby we can
hold on to the promise of god but it is
christ that saves us this must never be
misunderstood
or lost sight of nothing can replace
christ
as our savior and our preserver
our redeemer but he says you access that
by faith you know sometimes if i put oil
in my car
and i take off the the cap i get a
little funnel from the gas station
and i pour the oil into the the car now
without the fun of the braces blowing
the oil make all over the place the
funnel
is the means whereby i get the oil into
the the engine of the car faith is the
funnel whereby god pours the oil of
salvation into our lives
we must have that faith where it's not
the funnel that causes the car to run
smoothly
it's the oil but to get the oil into the
car you need that funnel to direct the
oil down
faith is the means whereby the oil of
christ
can be poured into our sinsic souls and
transformers
amen amen thank you elder skeet for
answering those two questions now i'm
going to bring
sister alana kwashion to ask the
remainder of
well the next three questions well two
questions or so
so sister alana kwashi you can come on
and ask
the next questions and i'll continue
monitoring the chat i see
mervis has also put something in the
chat we're monitoring zoom facebook and
youtube so thank you
all god bless
thank you denisha i am so excited to ask
you the next three questions
and the conversation has been going
really well thank you again for you know
coming back to answering more questions
so the first question is how do we live
righteous lives how do we live
righteous lives we read righteous lives
through
faith in christ that's always the spinal
cord
of a christian life it is through faith
in christ
but who is the father the faithful is
abraham
abraham expresses faith through
obedience to god
and as he obeyed his faith grow we live
a righteous life through obedience to
the word of god
and the power to obey is the very life
of christ it's almost
circular the power to obey is the life
of christ dwelling in us
listen to what paul says in galatians 2
verse 20
i am crucified with christ nevertheless
i live
yet not i but christ liveth in me and
you're asking how to live by faith
and the life which i now live in the
flesh i live by the faith of the son of
god who loved me
and gave himself for me the way i live a
righteous life is the way
jesus lived the righteous life in john
chapter 14
verse 10 the bible says believers thou
not that i am in the father and the
father in me
the words that i speak unto you i speak
not of myself
but the father that dwelleth in me he
does the works and this is not
this is literal the father
dwelt in the sun christ dwells in us
as verily as the father dwelt in the sun
and worked through the sun so very does
christ through his spirit
dwell in us and work through us and so
jesus could say in john 8 29 and he that
have sent me is with me
the father hath not left me alone for i
do
always those things that please him but
how was jesus
able to do the things that please god
because the father dwelt in him
through the spirit acts 10 38 god
anointed jesus christ of the holy ghost
and with power
through the spirit the father occupied
christ
to the spirit christ occupies us and how
does
christ occupy us when we take in his
word
it is all by the word as
verily as the word created heaven and
earth
considering that salvation is a work of
creation
so verily it is by the word that we're
saved and preserved
we live a righteous life by living in
harmony with the word of god
listen to ii timothy 3 16 all
scripture is given by inspiration of god
and is profitable for doctrine
for reproof for correction for
instruction in righteousness it is
through the word receive
believing that the word will do what the
word says as verily as i said earlier
let there be light produce light this
applies to any other promise christ has
made
if we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive
no one needs to walk around burdened by
the feeling i'm not forgiven
god has promised to forgive accept him
at his word
so we live a righteous life by living by
every word that proceedeth out of the
mouth of god
this was how jesus lived
i can't hear you my dear sister question
can you hear me now yes i can okay thank
you
um with that being said there was a
question in the chat in terms of how
we live righteous lives it said
how can we as sinners compare our
righteousness to
god's righteousness you just don't
because as a sinner you have none the
righteousness that covers you
is the righteousness of god the sinner
has no righteousness so there's no such
thing as compare
your righteousness with the
righteousness of god
the sinner has no righteousness of his
own or her own
we are covered by the right let's go to
zechariah chapter three let's read from
verse one
and let me pray again father as i
continue this very
very essential subject thank you for the
very excellent questions
speak through me god simply and directly
in the name of jesus i pray amen
zechariah chapter three reading from
verse one and the question is how can i
compare my righteousness
with the righteousness of god and i said
no sinner has righteousness
the salesperson's righteousness is the
righteousness of god
zechariah 3 from verse 1 and he showed
me joshua the high priest
standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand to
resist him
and the lord said unto said and the lord
rebuked thee o satan
even the lord which has chosen jerusalem
rebuke thee is not this a bran but out
of the fire
now listen to verse three now joshua was
clothed with filthy garments
and stood before the angel that's what
we have
filthy garments and he answered them
speaking to those that stood before him
saying
take away the filthy garments from him
unto him he said behold
i have caused that iniquity to pass from
thee and
i will clothe thee with change of
raymond
what naturally belong to joshua with the
filthy garments
what god gave him was his righteousness
symbolized by the road
when adam and eve were in the garden in
genesis 3 verse 7
and the eyes of them both were opened
and they knew that they were naked
and they sold fig leaves together and
made themselves aprons the aprons
representing the excuses we make for sin
and our efforts to deal with our own
sins that was theirs
you see rightfully theirs in verse 21
unto adam also and to his wife did the
lord god make cults of skins and clothe
them
in verse seven they made the quotes they
clothed themselves
in verse 21 god made the court god
clothed them
and god had to remove the aprons of
leave so the skills with which they left
the garden
symbolized the work of god the
righteousness of god
no human being can produce righteousness
of his own
or her own because the righteousness
that saves us
is produced from heavenly sir it is the
very righteousness of god
so there's no such thing as a human
being comparing his righteousness with
god
we have no righteousness of our own
it is the righteousness of christ
which is the righteousness of god and
the
the the concussive thing about the
gospel i see concussive
because it's so good it makes you dizzy
in a good way is that the gospel allows
god
to treat a sinner the way god treats
christ
the gospel allows god to love the sinner
just as if he just as he loves jesus
christ
but the righteousness that recovers us
is the righteousness of god
we have none amen
thank you so much for answering and
carrying on into
righteousness again um the next question
is
how do we hunger and thirst after
righteousness this is from matthew 5
6. does this have to do with eating the
flesh and drinking the blood of jesus
which is
is the same message in john 15 abiding
me and i in you
we hunger and thirst after right you see
when
someone genuinely comes to christ
and christ does that work of
justification
the person's great desire then is to
know
more and more of jesus the person
values christ so highly that
righteousness
becomes the person's priority now
jesus said in matthew 6 33 seek ye
first the kingdom of god and his
righteousness
and all these things shall be added unto
you all the necessities of life
will simply be added and i repeat simply
be added
if our priority is the righteousness of
christ in this kingdom
and so blessed are they which do hunger
and
thirst after righteousness they desire
to be like god
they want to be christ-like in all they
do and say and think
and that righteousness is pursued
through
the word of god studied and obeyed
elohim writes in christ object lessons
page 100 paragraph
one if studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart
subduing every unholy attribute
what is the power that does that the
righteousness of god in his word
so hungering and thirsting is a desire
to know more about jesus
and to be more like him and the power to
do that
is the creative word of god listen to
what eloise says in uh
education piece 15 paragraph two to
restore the
you know page 126 paragraph four the
creative energy that called the worlds
into existence
is in the word of god this word imparts
power
it begets life every command is a
promise
accepted by the will receives into the
soul
it brings with it the life of the
infinite one it transforms the nature
and recreates the soul in the image of
god this is what we must pursue
as our number one priority seek first
the kingdom of god
this is hungering and thirsting i want
to be like jesus
thank you following through with that
the question is how our justification
and sanctification shown in the
sanctuary well yes in the outer court
we have the main article in the outer
court was the uh
the altar of sacrifice then it was the
lever the label stood between the altar
sacrifice
and the entrance into the holy place the
oldest sacrifice represents cowspring
that's where the
the animals were burned christ gave his
life on calvary's cross
now this is it faith in christ's
sacrifice
leads to justification by faith faith
and the sacrifice is faith in christ
this produced justification now you've
got to live that life
which is in this the holy place where we
have the candlestick which gives
continual light
we have the shoe bread which is always
there the table was never without sugar
as a matter of fact the jewish tradition
tells us that when the bread was changed
on sabbath
it was changed it was such a refined
technique
that when the old bread was removed the
new bread was put
so quickly that the table not even for a
second was without bread
so we have bread we have light and we
have the incense
these things were continual continual
continual
but when a sinner brought a sacrifice
the sacrifice was burned that was it
but in the holy place we have the
concept of continual
the light was continually shining but an
animal wasn't continually burning it was
burned and burned up that's it so christ
died once he isn't continually dying or
continuing sacrifice
sanctification is in the holy place and
of course you can guess
that glorification is in the most holy
place
so study the court what happened there
study the holy place what happened there
you will see justification
sanctification
thank you so much now you also see that
way sorry to interrupt you okay you also
see that in john
chapter 15. if you read from verse 4
abide in me let me pray again father
continue to be with me please i pray
in jesus name amen john 15
4 abide in me and i in you now the greek
word
menos means to remain to stay
to continue so jesus and you'll notice
how often the word abide
occurs in john 15 1-10 on one occasion
is translated continue
it's the same greek word abide in me and
i in europe
as the vine cannot bear fruit of accept
as the branch cannot be fruit of itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
you except you abide in me which means
stay
still remain i am divine you're the
branches he that the body is in me
and i in him the same brain for much
fruit you go to verse six
if a man abide not in me he's cast forth
at the branch
you go to verse seven if he abide in me
and my words abide in you
he shall ask what he will shall be done
unto you you go to verse 10
if ye keep my commandments he shall
abide in my love
even as i have kept my father's
commandments and abide in his love this
is sanctification
a constant remaining a constant
remaining
so we have the instant act of
justification by faith we have
sanctification which begins at the same
time
it's a remaining it is a holding on to
what jesus did for you so as i said
earlier in a certain sense
justification is holding on with
increasing tightness
and clarity to what was done in
justification
there's no such thing as one save
immediately you always say
the bible says he that endureth unto the
end
you must remain in christ and this is
through constant prayer
and the study of god's word and
obedience to that word
thank you thank you i just have another
question in the chat
it says when we say the holy spirit
dwells in us
some people believe it is some sort of
possession
going on inside the person
and then on the other hand they refer to
the holy spirit
speaking to them being on the outside
or beside the person and they're asking
if you can clarify this
let's go to the bible at the bible
clarify john 14 let's read from verse
16.
john 14 for verse 16 and i will pray the
father
and he shall give you another comforter
that he may abide with you
forever even the spirit of truth whom
the world cannot receive
because he sees him not neither knoweth
him but you know him
for he dwelleth with you and shall be
in you when christ was with the
disciples
christ was not in them he was
with them through the holy spirit
christ dwells in us let me say it again
when christ walked with the disciples he
was
with them he was not in them
he said when i leave i'm sending someone
just like me
that's why the holy ghost is called
another comforter because christ was the
first comforter
just like me he will dwell not only with
you he shall be in you so yes the spirit
of god
dwells in us as
verily as a demon-possessed person is
filled with the demon
are you listening to me that has to be
cast out so a converted person
is filled with a spirit so you have
demon possession and you have holy
spirit possession
you must be filled the spirit he is in
you
speaks through you guide your thinking
as you continue to submit to god it is
not a force on the outside
like a battery pack you carry no no it
dwells in you
and that's how christ dwells in us to
the spirit that's why he says i will not
leave you comfortless i will come to you
so the spirit dwells in us as
the same way demons dwell in
demon-possessed people or in demon
possess
pigs the demons were inside if the demon
weren't outside why would jesus say come
out of the man thou
unto the spirit the demon is inside and
the spirit of god wants to be inside
because control is from the inside
mainly not from the outside
and so as much as a demon possesses a
person
and that person acts under the control
of the demon
when we voluntarily invite god's spirit
into us
we act under his direction
the difference is the person possessed
by the demon
cannot exercise the demon you see
someone else has to come along
but you and i can ask the spirit to
believe that's why there's freedom in
christ
let me say it again a demon
demon-possessed person cannot tell the
demon leave
the person has to be prayed for someone
feel that the spirit can tell the spirit
to leave
freedom in christ as so let me go again
and say
the spirit of god dwells within us now
can we understand all the mechanism
no but i tell you something you watch a
young boy
who tries to behave like some money
cease on teeth maybe a rapper
or a basketball player the spirit of
that player is in that
boy in a certain sense and so he walks
like his hero
he talks like his hero he wears his hair
like his hero he tries to play like his
hero
because in a certain sense he's
possessed by the spirit of his hero
and he behaves like him the spirit of
god must dwell in us
thank you thank you so much you're
welcome answering
these questions and then thank you for
coming back and answering our questions
i'm going to hand it over to denisha and
she'll actually the rest
all right god bless you sister thank you
god bless you also
thank you thank you so much sister alana
for asking those questions and elder
skeet for answering them
um and and i just want you guys to know
those of you that are on zoom
if you have a question that you would
like to ask directly
use the raise your hand feature and we
will allow we will unmute you so that
you can ask
your question this is a time for us to
clarify
any misconceptions about the word of god
and to affirm
our faith now elder skeet as usual the
time is 2
57 p.m
all right thank you so someone sent me
this message directly
how can i know that i am living
a righteous life obedience
simple obedience obedience is the
outward expression
of the internal state simple plain
and simple obedience out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth
speaketh what's in
comes out now under the new covenant
which is the only covenant whereby
anyone could be saved
all saved people are saved under the new
covenant by the way
that's how abraham was saved adam that's
how we're saved
the law of god is written on the inside
but how do i know it's written there it
produces an outward behavior obedience
is the evidence that i am
a child of god that's why faith a lot of
works
is dead faith must produce works
if my heart is beating i must see my
chest rise and fall
if i am breathing i must see a
cloud form in a mirror that's put to my
nostrils those are vital signs
vital signs are acts of obedience by the
spirit of god the power of christ
take away obedience and no one can claim
to have given the life to christ
obedience is proof that i have been made
right with god
but keep in mind we're growing we're
growing we become more and more
submitted and obedient
as we understand more and more but our
our
core belief is i have been changed by
god
i have given my life to god completely
then you grow in that state but
obedience my
dear friend was the question is the
evidence
that's why we're saved by faith we're
judged by our words
we're judged you said your christian
says god let me see your life
let me see your life a tree is known
by the fruit the fruits on the outside
amen amen you know it it also reminds us
that faith is
living we have no evidence no works no
obedience to show our faith that our
faith is dead
it's dead and you know i i see two
different questions which
speak to the same thing one was one was
uh
how is the righteousness of christ lived
out daily and practically
and as you would say that's by obedience
and and i guess if you like you can
expand on it and if you like or we could
just leave it at that it's obedience but
the bible says in psalm 119 verse 105
thy word is the lamp unto my feet and
the light unto my path they simply mean
the word teaches you how to walk which
is how to live
he the safety abideth in him ought
himself also saw the walk
as he walked first john 2 verse 6 to
walk means to live
so walk in the spirit you shall not
fulfill the lust of the flesh
that's living according to the
instructions of god's word
the evidence of a righteous life is
obedience to the word of god
and so when the devil tempted christ he
said man shall not live by brethren
but by every word by the way when he
said every word
he was referred to the commandments of
god which are the whole duty of life
yes yes amen i believe i had watched
your sermon when you explained it
what every word really means that it's
really the commandments
the commandments of god thank you for
that
now this next question is and we may
have touched on it before but how can
god's people
overcome evil
we overcome evil through the word of god
if you read first john chapter 3 verse 8
the bible says
he that committed sin is of the devil
for the devil sinners from the beginning
for this purpose the son of god was
manifested
that he might destroy the works
of the devil now you keep that component
you go to psalm 119 verse 11
thy word have i hid in my heart that i
might not sin
against thee so we have christ came to
under the works of the devil
we have the word of god hidden in the
heart in verse 9 of psalm 119
wherewithal shall a young man cleanse
his ways by taking he
there to according to thy word we have
some insight from el white
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one if
studied and obeyed the word of god works
in the heart
subduing every unholy attribute we want
an
easy way to conquer sin the word of god
is the way as the word enters us
the word and sin cannot occupy the same
space one has to go
as the word enters us something has to
leave
and that is sin that is why we read in
malachi 2 verse 6 the law of truth was
in his mouth
and iniquity was not found in his lips
listen to that again
the law of truth was in his mouth
meaning the priest
and iniquity was not found in his lips
because iniquity cannot found where it
cannot be found where the law resides so
as the law of truth is in his mouth
iniquity has to go we conquer sin
through a life of obedience to the
living word of god
and the other thing we have to avoid sin
as well you see you don't put yourself
in a sinful situation that's that
claiming god's promises
when god described job job 1 verse 8 he
said as thou
considered my servant job there is none
like him in the earth
a perfect and an upright man one that
feareth god
and as true with evil one way to conquer
sin is to avoid
circumstances that may make it easier to
commit that sin we must avoid
and but all the power all the strategies
are rooted
in the word of god it worked for christ
it'll work for us there is no way
to get around the word of god some of us
try
but you cannot get around god's word if
salvation is your desire
or an upright life is your desire you
cannot
get around god's word
amen amen god's word we we keep
getting redirected to the word
this is the blueprint that's the
blueprint this is the blueprint
now we have another question elder skeet
well two i think i mean
if no one else would like i mean friends
if you would like to ask your question
once again
i'm making the floor open just use the
raise your hand feature
and we will allow you to unmute
and ask your question but there are two
questions that i have
one of them was actually from the holy
spirit
and this one uh is from this uh
session right here someone is saying
what would you say about our children
who are not walking with god would you
say that they are coming from a bad tree
how old are these children
uh well children who have a sense of
right and wrong
each person has to be saved individually
now yes i can influence your life you
can influence mine
but ultimately we must we're saved as
individuals
assuming your children are adults they
are responsible for their own salvation
but their present condition
can possibly be traced back to how they
were raised
that does not mean a father or mother is
ultimately responsible
for an adult's direction in life our
children
children not walking in the way of god
are not walking in the righteous life
if i understood the question correctly
because a righteous life
is evidenced by the way you live
that's why we have the fruits of the
spirit love
joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness faith
meekness temperance though fruits are
grown on the outside
it is the life that determines if a
person is walking with christ or not of
course the ultimate judge is god
because some people can put on a very
good show as many pharisees did
but it is the life that determines if
someone is truly connected with christ
and if the life doesn't show it a person
a tree is known by the fruit by the
fruits
you know them if i walk by a mango tree
and i see
mangoes and i say that's a mango tree i
have not judged
if i see a man drink junk in the gutter
i said there is a drunk
i am not judging i'm not saying christ
will ever save him i am not judging
if i walk by the street at 11 o'clock at
night there's some women who dress half
naked and trying to proposition me
there are some prostitutes i am not
judging i'm simply saying there is the
fruit
and i'm identifying the tree someone
walking unrighteously is not a person
who has a connection with christ
a saving connection
even if the person's father is a head
elder and his mother's a head deaconess
the person's life says that person does
not
have a saving relationship with christ
amen amen and i i see chelsea has put in
the chat on that samuel the prophet's
children weren't walking in the way of
the lord
that's right but he was a servant of god
now that's not to give props to samuel
samuel was a poor parent now you
understand me
he did not fear it properly nodded eli
the high priest
but samuel will be the kingdom his sons
won't
because his sons could have chosen
differently when they reached the age of
accountability
they could have chosen differently
powerful powerful
brother archie actually just preached a
sermon about that this afternoon so
thank you all for sharing
your comments and more questions are
coming in let me open up the chat
these two are from youtube
okay someone says today at church this
is the good lovin today at church we
studied about
entering into the lord's rest would you
explain
what it means to enter into the lord's
rest and how important
should it be for each believer to do so
that's probably coming from hebrews
chapter 4
god promised abraham isaac and jacob
they would have the land of canaan
when he promised when he made that
promise to abraham he actually meant the
entire world not just cain and literally
which the jews did occupy or the
israelites he also met on a larger scale
the entire world
and paul makes that clear in romans 4 13
that when god
gave promise to abraham that he would be
the heir of the world
it was not by the law but by faith
now abraham died
never having uh occupied that land as
his
so did isaac so did jacob sorry joseph
they all died the rest of god
is not simply entering the physical
canaan it is
entering that state where we are no
longer bothered by the enemy of sin
and the ultimate rest of god will come
when christ finally gives this earth to
the meat
the meat shall inherit the earth the
israelites they occupied canaan but
there were always
wars going on they from time to time
they had to fight battles
so they did not have the ultimate rest
the ultimate
rest promised by god is the final
worldwide possession of this earth made
new
which will be inhabited by the meat
the meat shall inherit the earth this is
the
final rest where we'll no longer have
battles with our enemy
which is sin and satan the ultimate rest
but we can enjoy some of that rest by
faith now
by accepting those promises and
believing and looking forward to that
day
knowing that this life we presently live
constant battle of the enemy is coming
to an end so in a certain sense we don't
have the rest the total rest
that will come when this new world is
made new when the world is made new
and we inherit it as the descendants of
abraham
and so entering into the rest of god has
two levels
through faith in his promises which is
the meat shall inherit the earth that is
the promise
we accept that and we live by that
assurance even now
and so that if there's political turmoil
we are at ease
if there's a war we are at peace as
christ slept
on that boat in a storm and the
disciples were going out of their minds
we can live a quiet peaceful life
knowing
that our savior is coming to make it
right and will be a rightness that will
last forever
but even though we have that peace we
still see suffering all around us
just the sight of suffering interferes
with the arrest knowing that a family
member is not saved
interferes with your rest seeing someone
die of covid
interferes with your rest knowing
there's a drought somewhere
interferes with your rest because a
converted person feels for other people
the final and ultimate rest of god
is entrance into that new world where
all sin and the evidences and the
consequences of sin
are gone but until then we can have the
peace of christ
based on our grasping his promises
we believe is coming and so we hold on
but the ultimate rest is when we're in
the new world with christ
and sin is done away with the ultimate
rest is not even the thousand years in
heaven
because as we review the records we'll
see people we know
you understand we'll see people we know
it may be your mother your father your
cousin god forbid
but we'll see that when the thousand
years are over
christ comes back gets rid of the wicked
remakes the world and we'll see him do
it
then we finally enter the
ultimate and eternal rest of god
with no harassment from our enemy sin
satan death
amen thank you elder skeet now
sister christy bach i see that you have
asked about speaking in tongues
i'm gonna refer you to the q a on
the holy spirit we actually covered that
question
about speaking in tongues but sister
tamika
tamika william she has a question how
does a christian
deal with demon possession
now i'm not sure what she means by that
i mean if the person himself is
possessed and a christian should not be
possessed by a demon
or how do you respond to someone who is
demon possessed what do you do
now let me see quickly exorcism
is not one of the spiritual gifts listed
in the bible
and there's a reason why i say that
there are people who claim to have a
deliverance ministry there's no such
thing as a deliverance ministry
they go looking for the devil to cast
him out don't
do that you go looking you'll find
something you did not anticipate finding
if in the doing of god's work become
across the person possessed
we must respond in faith in christ
through the power of christ
we must command that demon to come out
in the power of christ matt uh acts
chapter 8
acts chapter 19 contains the story of
seven men who tried to cast out a demon
in the name of jesus but they did not
know jesus and the demon said i know
paul i know jesus who were you
the demon beat them up and they ran out
of the house naked and bleeding
don't play with the devil don't go
looking for people to exorcise
if in the doing of god's work
you come across that incident then you
have to respond
because christ died that people might be
delivered so we have the disciples
delivering
people in the bible so you have to
respond yes but don't go looking for it
and don't go in your own strength it
must be in the strength of christ
because the power that can cast out a
demon is
the power of god not the loveness of
your voice
it is the power of god and so what do
you do
you get someone with you in mark chapter
6 verse 7
verse verse six and seven i think it is
christ sent out the disciples
two by two and they cast out demons in
the name of christ two by two
have someone with you not because you're
scared but because you want to obey
christ's system there's a reason why
christ said go two by two
have someone with you or more than two
and pray
make sure you're right with god then
you've got to respond because we are
instruments god uses to express his
power to deliver other people let me say
it again
we are vessels god uses to pour his
power through us
to deliver other people but the power is
the power of god not yours
so when a christian comes across the
case of possession
the christians should act in the power
of christ
but don't go looking for demons to cast
out do not
do that amen amen thank you for that
answer sister tamika i hope that you
were able to
get your response um i see sister
carrell put another question i don't
want to take
too much more of your time elder skeet
because it is 3 14.
i i did promise my cousin that i would
ask you
his question his question
was for you to explain first corinthians
chapter seven
verse nine and let me see if i can read
it here quickly
i think this was in regard to marriage
and so forth
so let me find first corinthians chapter
seven
and verse nine lord goddess as we read
your word in jesus name amen
the bible says okay so but if they
cannot contain
so i guess i should start from verse
seven for i
would that all men were even as i myself
but every man hath his proper gift of
god one after
this manner and another after that i say
therefore
to the unmarried and widows it is good
for them
if they abide even as i
but if they cannot this is verse 9 let
them marry
for it is better to marry than to burn
so they can have two applications to
that but
one is better to marry than to burn one
can be to burn with lust
or the others to burn in hell because
you act on your lust
in an unmarried state are you following
me it is
better to marry than to burn if you
cannot contain yourself well get a
spouse
now of course we don't get spouses just
for the sake of satisfying
fleshly desires but the
the context in which to satisfy that
desire is the marital circle of the
marital context
and so when you're satisfied in that
context is not a sin
so paul says better to marry than to
burn whether burn in hell or burn by
constant desire constant desire
which may lead you to commit sin so
marriage
is preferable above burning in lust and
possibly leading to being burned in hell
but let me say again that's not the
ultimate motivation for marriage
amen lust is not the ultimate motivation
for marriage
i read somewhere ellen white was talking
to a young man
a couple actually she said if you can't
continue to say you might as well marry
and she gives him virtues marry and
start committing this sin
you know go ahead and marry and legalize
what you're doing
she give that counsel
amen interesting yes it's it's true it's
best we just do it the right way
but let me also say this there is power
to subdue that desire
there's power to control that lust that
power again is the word of god there is
power to subdue that listen to ellen
white again
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one if
studied and obeyed the word of god works
in the heart
subduing every unholy attribute subduing
there is no fleshly urge that the power
of god cannot subdue
if studied and obeyed and those of us
who live
outside the word of god we live in the
church but outside the world
we will run into these problems all the
time the word of god
studied and obeyed i cannot stress that
enough
will subdue any urge you have
along with as i said earlier avoiding
circumstances that excite that urge we
must also do that
because common sense is part of a
relationship with jesus christ
love that love that common sense is part
of our relationship with jesus christ
now
i'm gonna have to make these two the
last two questions all right
so someone has asked is it okay for a
christian to get life insurance
okay uh we've gone from the
righteousness of christ to all kinds of
subjects
uh the general conference put out a
statement seven years ago
about life insurance and you should be
able to find it on the internet you'll
probably
look for ellen white and life insurance
and you'll see a
fairly long they have a committee to
study the question
and the committee brought back several
recommendations with the church put up
to its to its uh body of believers
which is that it is biblical to make
to make provisions for tomorrow or for
the future it doesn't mean
you don't trust god but everyone comes
to us put aside something for an
emergency that may occur
this is intelligent living this is not
faithlessness this is intelligent listen
because anything can happen
the fact that you're a christian doesn't
mean you sit down and say lord you know
just get a shovel and throw rice in my
house
no we have to make steps we have to
think we have our mind we have to make
provisions
god has made a provision for the future
for us and so we should
take some intelligence steps to make
sure that as far as we can
we are providing some security based on
the resources god has given us
and so the church does not condemn life
insurance
the church tells us to pursue it in a
way that does not suggest we trust the
world
that we trust god but acting under the
guidance of the spirit but you should
the person should go on the internet
look for ellen white and
life insurance and i'm sure the person
will find that statement from the
general conference
but the church does not condemn life
insurance ellen white has a full
statement of life insurance it was
written when the industry was
unregulated
it was just in the 1860s it was just
unregulated like you know the wild wild
west
but it is not the same thing now it is
not the same thing now
and so the church recognizing that
having studied her writings
and the bible gave us these
recommendations to pursue it carefully
knowing that god is our ultimate
provider
amen and thank you for that reference
elder skeet i'm gonna have to make this
the last question i'm sorry everyone
but someone has asked when it comes to
the bible
people often times say it doesn't matter
what you believe
as long as you are sincere do you agree
with it
that's not true at all the bible says we
must worship god in sincerity and truth
in first corinthians 5 7 i think it is
in seminary
in sincerity and truth
it matters absolutely what you believe
because if you believe you know when
jesus healed the man in matthew
12 the pharisee said this man doth not
cast out devils but by beelzebub the
prince of devils
now that's what they said however
sincere they were they accused christ of
using the power of the devil
being sincere is not enough you
must follow truth
and truth is thus saith the lord and so
we must
worship god in sincerity and
in truth sincerity by itself is
not enough there are people who will
kill you
thinking they're serving god and jesus
said that will happen john 16 verse 2.
they'll kill you and think they do god's
service they are sincere
god bless the person who asked the
question but let me say it clearly again
sincerity is
not enough you must have
truth
amen
and we're not to be led by feelings be
led by just said the lord
that must take delay sincerity can fall
behind
and must be guided by the truth
sincerity alone
is not enough aiming alone is not enough
you must aim accurately
amen amen thank you for that elder skeet
thank you for that answer and i'm just
yes let me jump in
here in john 6 many disciples left
christ because he said
eat my flesh drink my blood they did not
understand amen eat the word
and so the bible says in verse 66 of
john 6 from that time
many of his disciples went back and
walked no more with him then jesus said
to themselves will she out will he also
go away you know what peter said
lord to whom shall we go thou has the
words of eternal life
we're staying for what you say what you
say
thus said the lord this is biblical fact
you have the words of eternal life we're
staying
because you have thus set the lord
regardless of how we feel
when the bible says thou shalt not kill
it has nothing to do with how you feel
don't kill and so thus said the lord is
not attached so much to feeling
it is a heavenly the soul that sinneth
it shall die you confess your sins
i'll forgive you sincerity
must not be what leads the child of god
it has to be
truth the truth
thus saith the lord at all times
there is no exception to this at all
time thus
saith the lord it makes no difference
how sincerely you
observe sunday it is not the sabbath
amen amen and how tightly you hug the
girlfriend you live with
she's not your wife
truth must be our guide
all right so much for that amen thank
you all the skeet and i
i found the verse john chapter 4 verse
24 the bible says
god is spirit they that must worship him
in spirit and in truth
that is one that says sincerity and
truth first question five
sincerity and truth not just uncertainty
amen first corinthians 5. i haven't
found that one yet but we can look for
it afterwards thank you
verse five look at verse seven or eight
first seven
yes first corinthians five
yes yes you're correct verse 8 the bible
says
well i should start from verse seven
that's where the sentence begins
purge out therefore the old leaven
that he may be a new lump as ye
are unleavened for christ for even
christ
our passover is sacrificed for
us one therefore let us keep the feast
not with old leaven neither with the
leaven of
malice and wickedness but
with the unleavened bread of sincerity
and truth
there we go in the mouth of two or three
witnesses disclosed
first corinthians chapter 5 verses 7 and
8 and john chapter 4 verse 24.
sincerity and truth i believe is also
found in joshua
24.
i believe you also find it there look at
verse 14
tell me what that says let's go there
joshua
joshua chapter 24 and elder screen you
said verses 13 um 14 and 15.
yeah look between 13 and 15. okay let us
yep
verse 14. i should start from verse yeah
verse 14 the bible says
this is joshua's speaking really now
therefore
fear the lord and serve him in
sincerity and in truth yes
and put away the gods which your father
served on the other side
of the flood and in egypt and serve
ye the lord and we have this very famous
verse that comes
afterwards and if it seems evil unto you
to serve the lord
choose you this day whom he will serve
whether the gods which your father
served that were on the other side of
the flood
or of the gods of the amorites in whose
land
ye dwell but as for me in my house
we will serve the lord
amen amen god bless all sincere people
but he wants truth first
amen and persons in the chat sincerely
amen amen what are the people in the
chat doing
oh brother owner has said thank you
brother skeet sister colo had said
keep up the good work everyone excellent
program
shay okay shays asked if we could put
the verses yes i will put them in the
chat definitely
sister shade thank you all for tuning in
so many tarantula ross sister alberta
coley marsha h cindy dally christine
sister chelsea jack as usual my brother
anthony ralph i saw you were on
cousin errol henry thank you uh sister
stacy ann i saw you were on for a bit
and mom of course thank you very much
elder skeet we appreciate your sacrifice
of time
we always go over it's 3 27 p.m
so thank you so much for your sacrifice
of time and your love for
the word of god and for sharing the word
of god to those of you that are watching
on youtube um i see elder baxter
sister carrell wasson so many persons
christy bach
and the list goes on and on we have 62
persons on youtube and 86 here
on zoom and there are others on facebook
so thank you all for tuning in
we're gonna move right along um you know
elder skeet was speaking before about
how the cross
tells us that we do not do
the work of salvation on our own
it is the work that christ does and we
believe
having the faith of jesus is the belief
that christ
is more than able to do that work
on our behalves so brother jonathan
archie and i we had
recorded this song near the cross
near the cross i pray that you are
blessed by
this peace
[Music]
um
us
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
hey
is
[Music]
here
oh
see
[Music]
his friends
god
oh
[Music]
shall fly
the rest
[Music]
here
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
hey
uh
[Music]
amen praises be to god thank you
all for your time and for your presence
today and most of all
we thank god for his working
i once again extend special thanks to
elder randy skeet for answering the
questions through the quickening of the
holy spirit
sister kadesha modest thank you for
ministering
more than just a hill thank you sister
alana kwashi
for assisting and asking the questions
for the jonathan for accompanying me on
near the cross and producing the video
and thank you in advance mr cursa hunt
for the prayer
i also extend gratitude because an arrow
for making sure
that reference was preserved throughout
this encounter by muting and
spotlighting
persons thank you mom for your prayers
support words of counsel and
encouragement and thank you to all of
you for joining
this session sharing commenting asking
your questions
and subscribing and following now
i encourage all of you to tune in may
8th
may 8th at 2 o'clock p.m eastern
standard time
we will be having our fourth up
no not fourth our fifth episode of the
feel the pillar series and let me
share the flyer right now
this will be a q a with pastor stephen
bohr
on the state of the dead episode five
this is may 8th at 2 o'clock
p.m eastern standard time and i have
added the telephone number so that
persons that need to call in
you are able to call in uh and this will
be
on the state of the dead once again
elder brother robinson altino sister
stacy and brown brother anthony rouse
sister chelsea jack
will be helping to facilitate this
program as pastor stephen bohr answers
the questions so let me remove this
flyer now
and here we'll be answering questions
like what happens when we die
when will the dead be judged when will
the living be judged
do ghosts exist so feel free to save the
day
now sister curse hunt will be delivering
the closing prayer
for us sister curse the hunt you may
pray to close
thank you amen amen let us borrow heads
for prayer
dear heavenly father almighty god we
we come to you in prayer thanking you
with our hearts
filled with gratitude for this series
for life and for the opportunity to hear
your word
dear father we are grateful that we
could come together as brothers and
sisters
hungry to hear your word your truth we
pray to god
that we will continue to draw closer to
you
through your word help us to learn more
of christ and help us to be more like
christ
so by your grace and through his power
we can
overcome sin and live a life of
righteousness
we pray that lord that you continue to
bless pastor skeet
continue to bless denisha and her
ministry and
all of all the participants and everyone
who's watching
we pray for a blessing upon all of our
lives
help us to continue in the faith help us
to continue to hold on to your promises
help us to hold onto your word the
foundation our instruction for life
we pray that lord you'll continue to
bless the future
um episodes we pray that more
people not just for numbers sake but
just for
so for people to actually come and be
drawn to you with
a a genuine genuine desire to be more
like christ
and to be filled with your holy spirit
we thank you so much for life we thank
you so much for the sabbath
and we thank you lord for the
opportunity to get into your word today
we pray for another opportunity like
this and
and we pray when time is fulfilled that
we will
all under the side of my voice will meet
christ
in the air when he comes the second time
continue to bless all the hearers
and help us their father to not only be
hearers but help us to be doers of your
holy word
in jesus name we pray amen
amen amen thank you for that prayer of
intercession sister carissa
may the lord continue to bless you and
friends i know that we've been on for
quite a bit probably about what an hour
and 39 minutes
um and and you know we really cannot
stress how grateful we are elder skeet
that you have
taken the time out of your schedule to
do this we truly love
and appreciate you and your ministry and
kindness may the lord
continue to bless you my pleasure my
holy pleasure i'm very serious it's an
honor
to explain the word to god's people by
the way god has given you a lovely voice
god bless you
praise god thank you so much elder skeet
thank you
well friends i don't want to keep you on
too much longer
um and oh my mom praise god for my mom
elders
you know maybe maybe if the lord wills
we can even collaborate maybe this can
be something we do on a monthly basis we
will have to talk and see we'll have to
talk and see
i know you're very busy but if the lord
wills
so it shall be um but friends
you know just on a more serious note
we've covered a lot of information today
and even in every session that we've had
whether it was on the sanctuary the
sabbath the holy spirit victory over sin
uh righteousness by faith and then the
state of the dead let's really take this
time to reflect
what have we learned today what do we
want to apply to our lives
how do we plan to apply these things
that we have learned
to our lives let's just reflect on those
three questions all right everyone thank
you
so much again for tuning in may the lord
continue to bless
you and keep you thank you